es uno de los muchos grupos extremistas
compitiendo por el control del sahel el
estado islámico en el gran sahara y su
hasta ahora jefe abu walid el shaarawy
está muerto alineado con el
autodenominado estado islámico sigue
estrictamente la ley sharía y controla
la región a la fuerza son conocidos por
ataques indiscriminados en la triple
frontera de mali burkina faso y níger
pero no están solos en el llamado
triángulo del terror allá también está
llamado nusrat o el grupo de apoyo al
islam y los musulmanes
jn y emme por sus siglas estaba afiliado
a al qaeda y es conocido por atacar al
gobierno y a las fuerzas internacionales
presentes en varios países estas
milicias no sólo combaten a las tropas
extranjeras como la francesa sino que
también luchan por el control regional y
se adaptan rápidamente sobre cómo
gobiernan a través del terror a medida
que ambos grupos cambian sus demandas
dependiendo de la política local y
tribal cuando haya ausencia de control
gubernamental
para el ministro francés de asuntos
exteriores esto es lo que se necesita
cambiar el estado y los estados que sean
golpeados por los grupos terroristas en
el sahel necesitan retomar
progresivamente su lugar en la vida
diaria de la gente y permitir que
regrese a la estabilidad esas son las
apuestas críticas de esta situación
juicios y eludió de la situación
mientras la violencia continúa en
múltiples frentes una región entera está
lidiando con las ausencias
gubernamentales y las fuerzas
extranjeras combatiendo a los grupos
terroristas